حيث طرح رئيس بعثه الامم المتحده لدعم في
ليبيا عبد الله باتيلي طرح مبادره لاجراء
الانتخابات قال ان الهدف منها هو جمع
الاطراف الليبيه وتجاوز حاله الركود
الحاليه
وقلبت لينا بالامكان وضع خريطه طريق
للانتخابات بحلول منتصف يونيو حزيران
القادم واضاف في مؤتمر ناس صحفي بطرابلس
انه لابد من حوار رفيع بين الجهات الامنيه
وذلك من اجل التوصل الى اتفاق لضمان امن
الانتخابات
بالامكانه وضع خريطه طريق واضحه
للانتخابات في حلول منتصف شهر يونيو وسيضع
هذا الالتزام مجلس النواب والمجلس الاعلى
للدوله وقادتهما امام اختبار وسيكونون
موضع مسائله عن اقوالهم امام ليبيا
والمجتمع الدولي نعرف جميعا ان الانتخابات
لا تتعلق فقط بالوثائق الدستوريه
والقانونيه التي يحاول مجلس النواب
والمجلس الاعلى للدوله الاتفاق عليها منذ
اكثر من عام هناك قضايا بالغه الاهميه
تحتاج الى معالجه لضمان نجاح الانتخابات
من بينها تحسين البيئه الانديه وهناك
ضروره لاجراء حوار رفيع المستوى بين
الجهات الامنيه لتهيئه الظروف الامنيه
اللازمه للمرشحين والناخبين خلال
الانتخابات ولابد كذلك من مساعده المرشحين
الانتخابات الرئاسيه والتشريعيه على
التحرك بحريه في جميع مناطق ليبيا
وحذر بتيلي من ان اطاله امد الوضع الحالي
في ليبيا لن يؤدي الى
الاضطرابات سياسيه واجتماعيه والانهيار
الاقتصادي وقال ان الانتخابات ستعطي
الشرعيه للمؤسسات البلاد واوضح انه واذا
توفرت الاراده السياسيه لدى مجلسي الدوله
والنواب يمكن اجراء الانتخابات هذا العام
اعطاء الشعب الليبي فرصه اختيار قادته من
خلال صناديق الاقتراع هو بلا شك السبيل
نحو السلام والازدهار في هذا البلد
الانتخابات ضروريه لاعاده بناء المؤسسات
العامه والشرعيه التي تمثل الشعب الليبي
وتختمه الترتيبات المؤقته المتتاليه
والحكومات الانتقاليه المستمره الى ما لا
نهايه والاجسام التشريعيه التي انتهت
ولايتها هي سبب عدم الاستقرار الذي يعرض
هذا البلد للخطر اطاله امد هذا الوضع لن
تؤدي الا الى الانهيار الاقتصادي
والاضطرابات السياسيه والاجتماعيه وتفاقم
حاله انعدام الامن وكل ذلك سيؤدي في نهايه
المطاف الى تقويد سلامه اراضي ليبيا ووحده
شعبها